[Music]
good morning and welcome to trevor
phillips on sunday
this morning brings a little relief for
the prime minister labour's poll lead
seems to be falling omacron is in
retreat and the threat of a leadership
challenge is ebbing away
he's made peace with his chancellor on
the national insurance tax rise and this
week looks to be packed with news not
featuring parties or cake
a white paper on leveling up
talked with vladimir putin
more trooped for nato a visit to eastern
europe
lots of opportunities to look like a
statesman but he's not out of the woods
yet there's still the sue grey report to
come in some shape or form
and pc plod may be feeling some collars
at number 10 though that could take some
time
and perhaps more important than all that
voters will see the money vanishing from
their pay packets within weeks and
that's in addition to the looming rise
in energy prices
the former prime minister david cameron
once described mr johnson as a greased
piglet who would always magically manage
to wriggle free of trouble
let's see what our guests think
with world leaders focused on potential
war in ukraine we'll speak to foreign
secretary liz truss who will be flying
to the country soon as the uk considers
doubling the number of troops committed
to nato defense
she's also responsible for negotiating
with the eu over the northern ireland
protocol
we're expecting the government to
finally publish its plans for leveling
up this week so we'll talk to labour's
shadow levelling up secretary lisa nandy
we'll also get a view from one of the
regions those plans should benefit with
the mayor of west yorkshire tracy braban
meanwhile the government's facing a
number of challenges at the moment one
of those is from its own backbenchers
and supporters over the national
insurance rise that's coming in april
i'll speak to tory mp robert halfon
and with vladimir putin massing 100 000
troops on the ukraine border how would
the west really hit him where it hurts
if he invades
i'll ask one man who's had his own
run-ins with the russian leader and
survived campaigner and investor bill
browder
but first i'm joined by foreign
secretary liz truss good morning uh
foreign secretary
um
do you expect that if we can't find a
diplomatic solution
to ukraine the ukraine problem that
russia will either invade and occupy
or install a puppet government
well first of all the number one
priority is deterring vladimir putin
from taking that action
that's why we are offering to deploy
extra troops into estonia
we are providing more air support across
the black sea and we're supplying
defensive weapons to ukraine to make
sure that they are in the best possible
position
should vladimir putin try to stage an
incursion what i'll be announcing later
this week
is improved legislation on sanctions so
we can target more russian interests
that are of direct relevance to the
kremlin because we absolutely need to
stop this happening that is our number
one priority of course we'll use
diplomacy i'm traveling to ukraine this
week i'll be traveling to moscow next
week
however the number one thing that will
stop vladimir putin taking action is if
he understands the costs of that action
this could result in a quagmire and he
should be well aware of that well let's
take those steps one by one first the
military and then the economic um
i'm no defensive expert but a defense
expert but any armed conflict is going
to be in ukraine
and we already have a small number of
personnel there why are we sending
troops to estonia
well we already have troops in estonia
the enhanced forward presence as part of
nato and what this is about is
bolstering our allies in the baltics
they feel increasingly under threat with
russia's uh
aggressive behavior on the borders
through belarus but also
directly with the baltics so we are
supplying
further uh further troops as are our
nato allies we're also strengthening uh
around the black sea as well so this is
about making sure that we bolster our
nato our nato allies who we have direct
commitments to as well as supplying
those defensive weapons into ukraine to
make it much harder uh for the russians
to think it's an easy target yeah but um
the total in estonia will be 1800 troops
now
putin has 100 000 on the ukraine border
that force in estonia is a pretty small
bolster isn't it i mean he's not going
to take that seriously
this is part of a work with nato overall
so
our american our canadian our french
allies are all putting uh further
further forces to strengthen
nato's eastern eastern flank and that's
that's important uh
and the point i would make about uh the
threat from uh vladimir putin is it's on
the border of ukraine uh the ukrainians
will fight hard you know they are not
going to give up easily and this could
well result into a quagmire you know
like the like the russians saw
in afghanistan or chechnya so this is
not going to be
simple
for russia
we need to make sure that that's the
case well well let's think about how the
quagmire as you put it gets created
will
we as a country
support a ukraine resistance force if
they are invaded will we send them money
will we send them weapons does vladimir
putin need to know
that we may not put boots on the ground
but we will supply and support and fund
a resistance movement that will make
life difficult for him for years
we're ruling absolutely nothing out and
we're already supporting in areas like
cyber
in areas like intelligence so recently
we released intelligence that showed
that vladimir putin was seeking to
install a puppet government in kiev uh
we're working on other areas of support
i mentioned the defensive weapons we've
trained up twenty thousand ukrainian
troops say we will we will look at every
every option and we will work with our
nato allies to support the ukrainians
and support freedom and democracy and
that includes
providing money and arms to make
any russian occupation of ukraine as
difficult and frankly impossible as
chechnya was for russia we are already
supplying defensive weapons to the
ukrainians and we are supplying uh
training and the skills that they need
to be able to resist any russian
invasion
all right let's talk about the economic
sanctions i noticed that you you said
that you plan to bring in new
legislation um
as far as i understood it we thought we
had the powers to be able to do what was
necessary what what will be new about
the economic sanctions beyond the
you know
magnitude sanctions that have been
applied before what what do you what
have you got so currently the economic
sanctions are
fairly narrowly drawn
so we could only target companies with a
direct involvement in destabilizing
ukraine
what we are looking to do is widen that
so any company
of interest to
the kremlin
and the regime in russia would be able
to be targeted so there will be nowhere
to hide
for
putin's oligarchs
for russian companies involved in
propping up the russian state that's
what we are looking at doing this week
would that include for example
the capacity to seize property which may
not be
very far from where we're sitting here
which is worth
hundreds of millions of pounds in the
hands of uh putin's oligarch pals who've
put their money into london property
nothing is off the table and we're not
going to go into details of exactly who
and how we would target the sanctions
what the legislation enables us to do
is hit a much wider variety of targets
so there can be nobody who thinks that
they will be immune to those sanctions
so the message to mr putin and his
friends is
where have you got the money where have
you stashed it we're coming after it
absolutely and we are working very
closely with our allies including the us
including the europeans to make sure
that that is a
severe package of sanctions so the
russian government understand that they
will be hard hit in the event of an
incursion this is going to be very very
difficult for russia and we are working
on deterrence at the same time as
diplomacy persuading russia to
desist from
amassing troops on the border persuading
them to move backwards i don't want to
seem obsessed with the property other
people's property but
you know we've said a lot of this before
after the salisbury poisoning for
example and so on
and it seems that we haven't really done
very much to hurt the people who have
got all those big houses in in belgravia
or who have large deposits in london
banks is the problem here that in truth
you might say you want to do this but
the cost of it to this country
is dramatic for every
russian oligarch whose accounts are
frozen
that means that somebody isn't going to
get investment from that russian money
in this country for example to support
the leveling up
agenda is that the problem that it's
going to cost us to do this
we have seized over a billion pounds
worth of assets and we have put
sanctions in place on specific
individuals but what i'm saying trevor
is we want to do more vouchers we want
to do more and that is why we are
legislating to broaden our sanctions and
fundamentally the most important thing
is defending freedom and democracy and
that is more important
than immediate financial issues and that
is true not just for the united kingdom
but also for our friends in germany who
are now taking a much tougher line on
nordstrom 2. you know we cannot
favor short-term economic interests over
the long-term survival of freedom and
democracy in europe that's the tough
decision all of us have got to make okay
if it's that important are you going to
tell the germans it's time to cancel
nordstrom 2. yes well the germans olaf
schultz has said
that it'd be very difficult for
nordstrom 2 to go ahead in the event of
a russian incursion so we have seen a
toughening of the germans position on
that i had a good call this week with
the german foreign minister
and we're and we're supporting that we
absolutely do is if there's an invasion
nor stream two stops
completely and
one of the issues we have
is european dependence on russian gas
in the same way as we're seeing economic
dependence grow on china and we're
seeing increased use of economic
coercion by china we are seeing russia
use the fact that it is supplying gas to
much of europe as an economic tool and
we cannot allow that to happen and we're
aligned with the germans on that we're
aligned with the americans on that all
right can we go on to the second of your
three jobs you're such a busy cabinet
minister which is uh brexit um
elections in northern ireland within 100
days the uh democratic unionists are
desperate for either for a settlement of
the protocol
or the trigger triggering of article 16.
just to get clear first of all
do you have a date in your mind at which
you'd simply stop the clock and invoke
article 16 if there is no agreement on
the protocol how long are you going to
allow these negotiations to go on
the protocol isn't working i was in
northern ireland earlier this week
looking at what was happening on the
ground and people are struggling to
import
food and other products from great
britain and that can't be right because
we are a single country we're a single
market and people should be able to get
those goods
and products from gb into northern
ireland so i want to fix the protocol i
think there is a deal to be done we've
had positive discussions uh with the
european union everyone recognizes as a
problem and my priority is protecting
peace and stability in northern ireland
protecting the belfast good friday
agreement so i think and we are in
intensive talk so i saw marilyn cech on
monday in brussels he's coming over this
week on thursday for further talks and
in answer your question trevor you know
we need to make progress urgently on
this uh we've got a joint council uh
date the 21st of february and i want to
see
significant progress by then oh so
trader first of february if it's not
happening then article 16 swims back
into view
well we always retain
the ability to use a safeguard if we
have to i think by far the better option
is to make progress with the eu
to get a deal to get those goods flowing
because that's what the people of
northern ireland want they want to be
treated as part of the uk they want to
be able to access you know the parcels
they want their pets to be able to
travel freely you know they want to be
able to
get those products in from gb
but yes if we don't make sufficient
progress we will have to consider using
the safeguard mechanism which is
provided for in the northern ireland
protocol i mean that's what the
safeguard mechanism is therefore all
right let's let's uh let's come back to
i think the thing that will be
concerning most people
in most of the country today
in 60 days time every working person is
going to be hit with a national
insurance contribution uh increase of
1.25 percent that's 10
rise for most people
in practical terms the average household
that is something like 300 pounds a year
or according to the office of national
statistics uh six weeks shopping
supermarket that's going to be followed
we think by an energy price rise that's
another 600 quid that
another 12 weeks shopping for poorer
households a lot more now um
assuming you don't want
most of the country to spend
a third of the year not eating where is
where are people going to find that
money from
it is a very difficult situation
that that we face and that is faced
around the globe on the cost of living
because we are seeing the back washes of
the cavity crisis we've seen problems
with supply chains problem with the with
the delivery of goods and the best thing
we can do as a government which is what
the prime minister is doing is opening
up our economy helping the economy to
grow that's where we've now got the
fastest growing economy in the g7 we're
one of the most open countries where
people are able to get back to work
we're able to get the economy going and
ultimately we are going to pay the cost
that we generated during the covid
crisis
by economic growth and that's what the
chancellor's focused on that's what the
prime minister's focus on but of course
you know we do have to pay for the money
we spent supporting businesses and
supporting people during the coverage
crisis
it's not it's not an easy situation to
deal with but i think the public
recognize the public do recognize that
we now have higher employment than we
had at the start of the coveted crisis
and that really is a achievement but we
are talking about people in work and i
i've got to say this this is quite
baffling coming from
your government and particularly from a
co-author of a pamphlet which extolled
the verse to the virtues of free market
and low taxes uh the revolution wrought
by mrs thatch and this morning prime
minister and chancellor boast that
they're
thatcher rights um
now of course you've had to deal with
covid but margaret thatcher had to deal
with a war she had to deal with riots
and regeneration of the inner cities she
had to deal with double-digit inflation
throughout the 1980s she did not
impose new
taxes
this is not
conservatism as you have always told us
it should be
we want to see taxes come down
and the prime minister and the
chancellor made that very very clear
just increased into the highest
level uh a burden since actually several
decades
the issue is we need to get economic
growth up and we've already made a good
start by being one of the first
countries to
implement the vaccine program the
booster program open up our economy
we're now looking at what more we can do
in terms of freedoms that we can
exercise now that we've left the
european union for example making our
regulatory system better unleashing our
financial services industries but those
things take time and i think the public
appreciates that we spent a lot of money
during cable
we do need to pay that money back you
must understand why i'm puzzled
you're saying
we've got to raise taxes and we're going
to rely on growth that's what the labour
people come in and say this is not what
i expect from you liz trust
what i'm saying is that we've had to
take difficult decisions because of the
extraordinary circumstances we face
we are committed to cutting taxes we are
committed to driving up grace we are
committed to using our new regulatory
freedom all right okay look i mean
we could talk economics all morning but
let's frankly let's deal with the
politics of where we are at moment we
talked about some very serious issues
ukraine energy prices and all the rest
of it but the truth is there's no space
in politics right now
for the most part the political classes
and most of the country are thinking
frankly are waiting for sue gray isn't
your
government really paralyzed by the fact
that you cannot get past the behavior
the conduct of some people
who uh in whitehall in number 10 and
indeed some of our leading
political leaders
this is a problem of your own making
isn't it and in particular the prime
minister's making i don't recognize your
characterization of the situation it's a
coach i i have been spending my time
with ministers
in brussels
northern ireland you know i'm going to
ukraine we are
working to supply more troops to the
borders of the baltics we are working to
up our sanctions package we are 100
focused on our day job uh michael gove
is launching his new leveling up paper
uh we are working on the booster
programme which has been incredibly
successful you love those people
if most people trevor
what they want to see is they want to
see
the economy they want to see their taxes
come down don't they
the way we're going to be able to do
that is by getting the economy going
that's the way to bring down taxes
all right look uh before before you go
there's an uh there's a i imagine that
many of our viewers will want me to ask
you the obvious question you've been
asked several times you're the
longest-serving member of the cabinet um
you're a very senior person
um
you know you've got these three jobs
that you've got to got to do
i'm not gonna ask you the obvious uh
hypothetical question what happens and
so on but let me ask you this um
in the prime minister's own words
when it comes to number 10 downing
street the key to number 10 downstream
he said if the ball comes loose at the
back of the scrum it would be a great
great thing to have a crack at do you
agree
well the prime minister is having no i
think that's why before he was prime
minister i'm asking you if you agree i'm
100 focused trevor on
delivering on the northern ireland
protocol
on our foreign policy which is
very important at the moment where
one of the members of the permanent
security council the uk has a huge role
to play i can assure you that is taking
up all of my time and more all right
we'll return to rugby on another
occasion liz trust thank you very much
indeed now leveling up we've been
hearing that phrase near constantly for
many years now
well we're finally expecting the white
paper that should set out the
government's plans and maybe even what
it actually means any day now
meanwhile the government's announced
that 20 places in england including
wolverhampton and sheffield will be the
first to get money for regeneration so
let's get labour's view on that and much
more with shadow leveling up secretary
lisa nandy
good morning shadow uh shadow leveling
up secretary i nearly called you shadow
foreign secretary sorry um good morning
i've moved
the the prime minister's uh visiting uh
eastern europe uh next week do you think
that the government's doing enough
to protect the ukraine from the
depredations of mr putin
look i think the prime minister is right
to go and visit the region we've
criticized him for not going and i'm not
going to criticize him now for going
this is an incredibly difficult volatile
and serious situation i think the
defense secretary is absolutely right to
offer support and support around
intelligence support around defensive
capability i'd if i had one disagreement
with the government listening to liz
trust there
it was that it was quite extraordinary
that she
on the one hand was emphasizing the
importance of widening the sanctions
regime something we've called for for a
long time and working in concert with
our allies in order to implement that it
has far more effect on russia and on
president putin if we stand together in
the face of russian aggression but just
minutes later she was talking up a row
with the eu that the government has been
trying to keep going for the last few
years it seems to me these two things
are completely contradictory and most of
all not in britain's interests they're
certainly not in the interest of the
people of northern ireland but you can
see now why this is not in britain's
interests as a whole
the the issues around the protocol
could be dealt with with some creativity
and goodwill and i think the government
really ought to reassess the way that
it's handled that in the light of this
very serious situation that's developing
on the border of ukraine
so
but broadly speaking you you support
what they're doing
would there be things that you
would do
in addition
yes we've long called on the government
to widen the scope of the magnitsky
sanctions these are sanctions that apply
to individuals
and when the government introduces
it
forgive me it sounds from what liz trust
said that that's actually what they're
about to do would you will you be
supporting legislation if that's what
the effect of them that legislation is
if they do we've campaigned for it for
several years we pushed the government
to do it originally and i think my
understanding was that that was blocked
by the treasury if the treasury has
finally realized that that was a mistake
of course we'll support that and i think
the important message
from britain has to be that we stand
united in the face of russian aggression
with nato and with our allies we will
not allow this to stand and all
political parties should be working to
that end
there is a tricky um
issue to solve here there are worries
that the kremlin might put the squeeze
on by restricting gas exports to europe
and a third of uh
europe's gas comes from from russia
market prices are already incredibly
high they're going to go up again
we're going to face our own
problems um
do you think the uk can actually afford
to do what is necessary for example
liz trust more or less said
if there's an invasion
that we should
put put a stop to nordstrom too do you
think we can
afford to do that
well i think there's two things the
first is that we've got to work very
closely with countries like germany that
are heavily much more heavily reliant on
on imports of gas from places like
russia to make sure that we're all
working together around this and i agree
with liz trust that
economic expediency cannot come before
security and the defense of the united
kingdom and the defense of democracy but
you know for over a decade now we've had
this
very very confused energy policy that's
been pursued by the government we've
lost a lot of our gas storage capability
that was given away
several years ago we haven't invested
sufficiently in
in renewables particularly around solo
the government took the ax to solar a
few years ago and removed the subsidies
that were that cut off at the knees an
industry that was really thriving and
developing grubs jobs growing at six
times the rate of the wider economy i
think we're now starting to see the
folly of that approach
being played out
at the border of ukraine
and that's one of the reasons why we've
been saying for some time now that not
only would investment in renewables
and in the energy industry and in
helping energy intensive industries to
adapt do a huge favor to many parts of
the country that desperately need to see
new jobs and investment and good wages
in them
but that at the same time it would help
us to cut carbon emissions and reduce
our dependence on imports of gas from
companies that come from countries like
russia and qatar that's got to be the
right approach and i hope that finally
after a decade of inaction the
government is going to wake up and
realize that this is critical to our
national security and critical to our
future prosperity
all right let's uh if i may i uh let me
catch up with uh with history and move
on from your old job to your current job
which is sharon shadow leveling up
secretary you you praised the um
the government's uh
desire for leveling up uh and in places
like grimsby where you
and your leader were this
week to look at investments uh that's
taking place in offshore wind power um
do you want to see what do you want to
see more of in the leveling up white
paper
well look we welcome the small pots of
money that have been announced for 20
places today that's a a small refund on
the amount that we've lost since the
prime minister took office and i think
those 20 places will be glad to have any
penny back that they can get because any
penny counts but i think there is a
profound sense that the government has
really missed the point with the very
small
beer that they've given us this morning
they've got to get money back into
people's pockets right across this
country town centres are are not
thriving high streets are falling apart
because not only have we seen good wages
good jobs depart from many parts of the
country over recent decades it's been
turbocharged in the last 10 years and
right now energy bills are going up
shopping prices are sky high and people
are about to face a tax hike michael
gove talks about king's cross style
regeneration but if you want king's
cross style regeneration you've got to
put money back into people's pockets so
that they can spend you've got to get
those good jobs back in king's cross
cost three billion to redevelop the
government's stake alone was worse three
times what they're giving to the entire
rest of the country with this money
that's been recycled from the budget
these are places that within living
memory powered this country places like
grimsby places like wigan and we deserve
the right to make that contribution
again that we are ambitious for this
country why isn't the government
oh yes but i'd like to
ask you lisa nandy
what what would you do i mean when you
uh talked about leveling up this weekend
and previously you've got
particular interest in the position of
towns um
one of the things that you've said is
that you don't want people to have to
get out to get on that they don't have
to leave where they've grown up and live
in order to get good jobs to be socially
mobile and so on
how do you want to achieve that and
what's it going to cost
so we want young people to have choices
and chances and we've already made a
significant commitment from a future
labour government as to what that would
mean 28 billion pounds investment every
year for the life of the next parliament
in green energy that means the sort of
jobs and apprenticeships that i saw in
grimsby with kierstarma last week the
sort of chances and choices for young
people that are too often denied to them
unless we take that seriously unless we
get that investment back into places the
transport infrastructure the digital
infrastructure so that we can leverage
in private sector investment it's
businesses in grimsby that have been
driving that improvement and getting
that investment into grimsby and those
opportunities back again unless we do
that unless we rebuild the foundations
of our local economies and allow people
the chance not just to have jobs but
good jobs again that make a contribution
we will have profoundly missed the point
that's what is so disappointing about
the government's announcement today
we've got to be far more ambitious than
that
yes you've
okay let's you you've been saying for a
couple weeks now that the whole part of
gate saga and so on has been distracting
the government um two weeks ago you said
that prime minister's position was
untenable um
but he's still there
the delay around the su grey
report and the mets launching its own
investigation probably mean that
actually that's going to be the
situation
for some time possibly for months
has labor missed its shot
at the prime minister
look the prime minister could end this
circus today he could just be honest
about what has been going on you and i
know he's not going to he you and i know
he's not going to your job as opposition
if you as a way you describe it is to
get rid of him have you missed the
opportunity did you fumble the ball
well in the end it's it's up to two
groups of people tory mps who could if
they wanted to trigger um for the prime
minister to go or back a vote of no
confidence in the house of commons but i
think it's unlikely both have no
confidence moved by the labour party or
or
it will move by the labor party if tory
mps will support it there's no point in
just perpetuating the circus people have
got real problems
or it's up to the public in the end the
prime minister if he stays will have to
face the public in a general election
but just consider for a moment what you
said trevor we just agreed and moved on
very quickly from the idea that the
prime minister could put an end to this
be honest and come clean but he's not
going to that is why this circus is
continuing that is why the country is
being held back that is why this
leveling up white paper frankly doesn't
appear to be worth the paper that it's
written on these promises that have been
made to us are not being kept because
the prime minister is saying yeah but
it's not a criminal investigation to
tell him whether he was even at a party
i guess but it's not my opinion
it's it's not my job to make moral
judgment about the prime minister what
i'm asking you
is if you think it's all so terrible
he's so ghastly he's making a mess of
the country
why haven't you been able to do anything
about it that's the job of opposition
and i'm just asking you whether you
think
uh when you had the opportunity
you missed it
well just i don't know what you're
asking me to do do you want me to go
down to london now and frog march him
out of downing street i mean in the end
we live in a democracy and if tory mps
won't find the backbone and the courage
to do the right thing then it will be up
to the british people what we'll do is
the official opposition is leave no
stone unturned we will not rest until
people who have been bereaved people
who've lost loved ones people who made
huge sacrifices have got answers from
the prime minister about what was going
on on his watch and will continue to do
our job in speaking up for people who
are watching these broken promises with
utter dismay people deserve better
chances and choices than the ones that
are currently on offer to them they deal
they deserve a government that will deal
with the cost of living crisis and will
actually start to rebuild our great
towns and cities right across this
country and until they have one we
simply will not rest that is our job and
we will do it
lisa nandy thank you so much for your
time this morning
conservatives generally don't like
putting up taxes but the prime minister
and the chancellor have confirmed once
again that they're going to be doing
just that in april and in a pretty big
way
national insurance will go up by one and
a quarter percentage points for both
employers and employees that's about a
10 rise for most of us
and is the first time that millions will
have experienced an actual cash cut in
their take-home pay due to tax
and it's going to take effect just as
energy bills saw by as much as 50
we're told
and all that is making tory mps and
probably some ministers too
very nervous
i'm now joined by conservative mp and
chair of the education select committee
robert halfon good morning mr halfon
good morning good morning now the prime
minister and the chancellor have written
a joint article in a newspaper this
morning declaring rise in national
insurance uh has to go ahead you have
said you don't like it but um
have you lost the battle
well i agree with the government that we
need the money for the national health
service and social care there's an
umbilical cord between the british
people and the nhs and they want that
money spent i also agree
that we shouldn't borrow to pay for this
because all that does is defer
tax rises and also puts pressure on
interest rates what i'm just asking the
government to do is to go back to the
drawing board and look at how they raise
that money and i've suggested that the
government looks at windfall taxes on
big business particularly oil companies
for example who've been breaking it in
over the past a couple of years perhaps
increase capital gains tax
as well so we can raise those funds for
the nhs without hitting um low income
workers
this is very interesting i mean um if if
i didn't know that you're a conservative
mp i would have
uh
assumed that that was a labor mp
speaking because that is precisely what
the labour party says it wants to do and
precisely what the prime minister and
the chancellor said that they'd never do
well i don't think the labor party of
proposed windfall taxes on oil but what
um if you go back to margaret thank you
you sat there rachel reeves stood and
talked to me and said exactly those
words well if you if you
that's fine but if you go back to
margaret thatcher and you were talking
about mrs thatcher earlier she imposed
windfall taxes on the oil industry she
put taxes on banks because they needed
to raise uh money and extraordinary
circumstances we face emergency
circumstances now because of the rise
huge rise in energy bills up to two
thousand pounds we've got petrol and
diesel nearly reaching one pound fifty
at the pumps we've got inflation over
five percent so families are facing a
real struggle uh to feed uh all their
that you know their families and uh pay
their cloak pay for the cost of clothing
and the cost of living is is a huge
problem at the moment
you can understand mr health and why i'm
slightly disconcerted this this morning
i i have um the foreign secretary coming
in and telling me
after she has for many years been seen
as a tax cutting uh thatcherite uh
member of parliament you know the
pictures on tanks and all of that
telling me oh well sorry gotta put up
taxes and now you're telling me what the
government that you support which is
actually in government and has
the ability to do this should really
implement a labour programme
i don't accept as a labor program i'm
i'm a practical conservative as i said
mrs thatcher imposed windfall taxes on
the oil industry and put taxes on banks
to raise uh vital funds that were needed
during the
1980s and if i have a choice between
taxing low-income workers so if you're a
worker on 20 000 pounds you're going to
be paying an extra 90 pounds if you're a
worker on 30 000 pounds you have to pay
an extra 214 pounds with this tax that's
a huge amount of money especially with
costs in energy going up in petrol and
diesel and food and and everything else
so a much better option in my view would
be a win for tax on a big business so to
pay for that that would pay for the nhs
money that is that is needed without
hitting low-income workers
all right well look i mean
let's let's suppose that the chancellor
um
decided that what he'd written this
morning was wrong having listened to on
this program
that would be an extraordinary blow to
his authority not to mention the prime
minister's were he now to change his
mind
you can't possibly expect that to happen
can you
well the chancellor and the prime
minister set out their view
in the newspapers this morning i
understand that it is a very difficult
financial situation all i can do as a
backbench mp represent my constituents
in harlow is trying campaign to cut the
cost of living because as i've mentioned
they are struggling to
feed their families and
i get emails every day from uh people
who cannot afford their energy bills as
it is they were going to go up
potentially to 2000 pounds a year that's
going to be unaffordable and we've got
another pot of money the government have
cut overseas aid that's a separate
argument that people will make whether
it was the right or wrong decision but
that has raised 4 billion pounds we
should use that 4 billion pounds to cut
taxes or cut the 80 for the lower paid
let's talk a bit about the politics of
this um let's suppose that the
tax rise does go ahead how seriously do
you think that uh will affect the
conservatives uh electoral support do
you think that's really going that will
be an issue
well of course people are struggling
with the cost of living so if they can't
afford to pay their bills they're hardly
going to be
very positive towards the government so
it depends uh what the government does
in other measures to try and mitigate
against that we're told we're going to
have a cost of living package
in february i hope very much that
that takes place and i'll look forward
to see what the government is proposing
but it has to be urgent action because
people are struggling as i say to pay
their bills
uh the other aspect of what the public
may be thinking about in relation to
politics this uh this weekend and you
may have heard this from your
constituents
is of course uh what various people in
government and in whitehall did during
covet you actually as i understand it
had to shield
at various points during the pandemic
how do you feel
looking at those pictures hearing the
account of those parties and knowing
what you had to do about what was going
on in government while you were
shielding
well yes because i have
bought cell will pause in
other problems i did have to shield but
my positions harlow many people because
country had it much worse off than me
and they suffered terribly by not being
able to see their
relatives uh or or people
sadly passing away and not being able to
see their loved ones as they were uh
dying so we all feel um hugely let down
by what has uh gone on it shouldn't have
happened i had constituents talking to
me about it only yesterday in harlow how
upset they were as to what had happened
in downing street and what i've called
for is for three hours from the
prime minister for him to respond to the
anguish of the public to take
responsibility for what has happened and
to reset the government and focus on the
genuine people's priorities like uh what
we've just been talking about
robert is there four are possibly there
which is resign
i'm not agitating against the prime
minister i'm certainly not putting a no
confidence motion for two reasons first
of all i don't think the public would
welcome bloodletting or change of
government in the midst of a crisis in
terms of eastern europe in terms of uh
the economy and the cost of living
coming out of kobe and secondly i do
accept that i owe the prime minister
some residual loyalty not just for
winning the 2019 election and for brexit
but also for the vaccine program for the
jobs miracle we've got
in our country and uh i think those are
important things to
to to remember but that doesn't mean as
i say i don't want
the pr i want the prime minister to take
responsibility to reset the government
and respond properly to the public
thank you robert halfon and i i i will
take the phrase residual loyalty with
some seriousness we know that we'll talk
about this again
now back to leveling up it's an
extremely important concept for a
government that used to used it to win
seats in northern labor heartland and
for the communities that hope to benefit
from increased investment
but what does it mean
and will communities that felt left
behind really feel a difference
well we should know more very soon
so let's speak to the mayor of west
yorkshire tracy brabin
may thank you so much for joining us
now the government's expected to publish
this long delayed
white paper on uh
leveling up next week
do you expect it to deliver what you
have said that you wanted and
helped to bring an end to the
north-south divide
well thank you for having me on trevor
and certainly the government seemed to
have acknowledged the issue around
leveling up that we need to rebalance
the economy across the uk and ensure
that health and wealth and opportunity
is shared and new money is always
welcome but after decades of
underfunding the question will always be
is this going to be enough now of course
looking we don't have the detail but it
does seem to be a focus on affordable
housing which i'm really pleased to see
as someone who grew up in social housing
i know what a secure tenancy can do
to enable you to fulfill your potential
but it has to be about more than that it
has to be about skills when 50 of the
working population don't have digital
skills it has to be about climate change
when businesses are washed away every
two years by flooding you can't level up
that community and culture you shouldn't
have to leave your community to go to
london to fulfill your dreams and
finally it has to be about transport and
connectivity i've been on your program
before trevor talking about our
disappointment on the integrated rail
plan and now we have a crisis in our
boss network that lack of clarity from
governments about how much money and if
they're going to give any money to the
bus companies after march has meant that
bus companies are cutting routes in
exactly the places that need leveling up
like the five towns in wakefield so it
does feel like every single department
has to work together it cannot just be
about one person in cabinet making these
decisions we need everybody to pull
together and unfortunately we haven't
seen that from the treasury as as yet
let's i want to come back to the issue
of buses in a second but just before we
uh go on to that indeed the last time we
spoke
um it was before the announcement on hs2
and use told me that what you really
wanted was a station in bradford a few
days later the government announced its
plans and there will be no new station
in bradford there is an issue
of trust here isn't there because at
that time i think
you had
uh sort of um you thought that the
government might be on the same page as
you they clearly weren't um what makes
you think that you can trust them now
well you're absolutely right we were
poorly served with the integrated rail
plan the 96 billion that government
announced um it turns out that seven
billion is for west yorkshire six
billion goes for the transparent upgrade
which is the electrification of that
line between manchester and leeds which
leaves us
the the grand sum of one billion pounds
which is for electrification between
leeds and bradford and sadly a survey on
how we can get faster trains from
sheffield to lead so
disappointing and when i pressed
government to give us the detail of
where they were making these decisions
it seems that government and treasury
are just thinking about cost and this is
why i'm saying that people and
departments need to work together
because the idea of leveling up wasn't
factored in it wasn't factored in about
the opportunity for the people of
bradford to have a new station and what
that would impact and the money and
investment that would bring you see that
in the midlands that the just the pure
announcement of the new stations and the
new um the new rail network that brings
investment that wasn't uh in the
equation when government were looking at
what they would do with the integrated
rail plan so i will continue to press
the case but yes it was incredibly
disappointing
let's pick up a couple of the points
you've mentioned this morning first of
all on buses
how serious uh will it be do you think
if you don't get
um
the services that uh so i understand
something
that cut in half in some parts of your
your area um
what impact is that going to have and
how serious how big a deal is it for you
it's a massive deal if you live in a
community that doesn't have a railway
station you absolutely need the boss
network and that's why when i stood to
be the mayor of west yorkshire i stood
on a manifesto of improving uh our boss
offer we've allocated a million pounds
to investigate uh public control because
we know that at the moment a boss
network that works for profit this is
where you end up when government and the
bottom line doesn't work and government
don't support you then sadly you're
starting to make cuts to that service so
we're getting
people approaching us telling us that if
that bus network if that route ends
they're going to have to walk to work
we heard a couple of months ago of a
group of
workers who the only way they could get
to work economically to make it work
because there was no bus route was all
of them to go in one car and one of
their colleagues to travel in the boot
this is not good enough this is not the
west yorkshire i want to see we need a
proper bus network and if you're not
going to fund us on the trains please
when when we have our bus service
improvement plan i've been saying to
government we need the money we have a
transformational offer for government
you can't then ensure that the money
that we are uh allocating for bus
transformation is actually about then
managing decline of the boss network
crikey that's that's a heck of a story
about you know boots somebody being in a
boot but um do you agree with
your
manchester mayoral
colleague andy burnham that key to this
is not just the number of services
but their cost and he's been pressing
the case that uh in london you can
essentially um have a single bus journey
for one pound 55 whereas in your part of
the country it is far more expensive
what would you
put that
subsidy for um
fares
as a priority for example over
fresh services
well i would suggest we shouldn't have
to choose obviously london doesn't have
to choose whether they get the service
or they get the fares it is part of a
complete package a fair tap in tap out
capped fair green buses
and routes where you you need to get to
that serve colleges workplaces and so on
but of course it's also about um
affordability we have seen the cost of
living crisis the uh your other guests
spoke about that quite eloquently that
the the public are going to have less
money in their pockets and if you use
the buses on a number of trips you are
paying more because it's not capped than
those people who just use one boss to
get to work and back so my plan is to
cap the fare at five pound fifty and
we're working with bus companies already
we're not sat on our hands waiting for
government we're already working with
bus companies to try and make that
happen it's fair it's equitable and it
will mean that more people have access
to the boss
tracy brogan thank you so much for
joining us this morning
we started this program talking about
ukraine and let's finish
by doing just that it's incredibly
important an extraordinary consequential
subject as the great powers of the west
square up to vladimir putin
bill browder has had his own battles
with the russian leader which led to new
laws enabling targeted sanctions to
seize money from individuals as we heard
from the foreign secretary earlier
he thinks taking that approach against
putin himself is the only way really to
hurt him especially with so much russian
money in london
bill browder joins me
now
good morning mr browder um
what do you think will be the most
effective way
to deter vladimir putin
from an invasion of ukraine
vladimir putin is first and foremost a
kleptocrat
uh he's been in power as a dictator for
20 years
he's stolen an enormous amount of money
from the russian state
from russian oligarchs from from others
in russia
and that money he doesn't keep in his
own name he keeps in the name of
trustees i call them oligarch trustees
and those oligarch trustees don't keep
that money in russia they keep that
money in the west and as you mentioned
we see it in london we see it in new
york we see it in south of france
and putin values that money more than
human life he's killed a lot of people
to get that money
and so in in in my mind the the the
cleanest
safest and simplest way of deterring
vladimir putin from invading ukraine is
to go after his money and there's a
piece of legislation in place it's
called the magnitsky act it was named
after my lawyer who was killed in russia
sergey magnitsky
and it allows the british government
to freeze the assets and ban the visas
of people who are involved in high-level
corruption and human rights abuse
and so we have a tool the magnitsky act
we actually know who these oligarchs are
and hold putin's assets um we know that
they are held in in london and we know
that putin values his money and so the
easy way of doing things for us
and a very asymmetric way as far as
putin is concerned is to freeze the
money of a certain number of oligarchs
and i would argue that we should do so
before he invades ukraine to show that
he were serious instead of waiting for
him to actually cross the border
do you think um
that
some of this has been done
already or is is your case is your
concern
that
the money is too important
to the uk you know the property the
investments and so on for us to really
do this seriously
well
it's an interesting question because on
one hand um i would i would i've seen
and i think everyone else has seen
that um we've been pretty soft on russia
here in the uk um in the past they've
they've committed uh terrible atrocities
using novichok and salisbury and
polonium in london
the russians have been
sending
jets over our uh you know military jets
in in the
uh over our airspace they've been doing
all sorts of terrible things
and we haven't done much and and the
reason we haven't done much in the past
is because um of all this russian money
sloshing around and a lot of people
close to the center of power benefiting
from it but and this is a really
important but um
we're now in a new world where where
russia is is threatening the stability
of peace in europe and um and because
all that money is still sloshing around
here it gives us what i would call an
enormous amount of leverage we're
actually we could potentially punch way
above our weight um because all that
money is here and if we started to
freeze it and seize it i guarantee you
putin would pay attention
yeah but of course the the other way of
looking at this is there's all this
money sloshing around there are a lot of
people here benefiting from it and i
don't just mean you know um fat cats in
the city but i mean for example people
who might benefit from investment of
that cash
freezing and seizing the oligarchs money
is not
a pain-free process for britain is it
well well i i would argue that that is
it's very pain-free in the sense that
that they can't that there's no there's
no reciprocal measure that they can take
against us so it's not as if we have all
of our money in russia they have all of
their money here and they could
reciprocate um this is something that we
can be done asymmetrical so and so we
can do it and there's no way that they
can retaliate against that and so yes
there are people um in in the city of
london and people in the house of lords
and and other places who are
beneficiaries of this money but the but
their interests
these people's interests are are so
trumped by by the interests of national
security that they if if they have
anything to say about this they should
just keep their mouth shut at this point
because putin is threatening the peace
peace and stability of the world
um you mentioned the house of lords now
of course we all have to be rather
careful about what we say about
individuals and so on but is your point
that you think that people in politics
including in our legislature are
benefiting from the money uh held by mr
putin's associates
there's no question that that's the case
um uh i've seen it firsthand uh members
of the house of lords from from uh both
major political parties were taking
money um from russians specifically um
to target the weakening of sanctions and
weakening of magnitsky sanctions and so
i've seen it uh
with my own eyes and that's just a tip
of the iceberg so yes there are many
people here who um do take russian money
um but at this point in time anyone
who's taken russian money should recuse
themselves from the conversation about
what to do about putin going forward
because we're now facing such a dire and
dangerous situation
liz trust talked this morning about new
legislation to
allow the government to take action
against uh putin associates
whether or not they were directly
involved in some way in the ukraine
situation do you think that's necessary
and a good thing
well um i'm glad to hear that and um
it's really that's the key point um i
don't think they actually need new
legislation the existing legislation
allows them to do that but if they want
new legislation so be it and and god
bless them for doing that um the key is
to go after these people because this is
where our leverage is and so it's a it's
i'm very hardened uh to hear hear her
say that and and let's hope that this
thing
the legislation gets put in place and
more importantly that it actually gets
used properly because the the big the
big problem with these situations is um
governments all over the world always
want to be seen to be doing the right
thing but often are scared to do the
right thing um to really do the right
thing one has to make a list of the top
50 um oligarchs who are looking after
putin's money
and then start to sanction them and and
everybody who's involved in that knows
how angry putin will get and they're
kind of scared of making him angry but
this is the one thing that he'll listen
to
you um
mentioned earlier on in this
conversation
your lawyer and i think your friend
sergey magnitsky who was killed uh in
2000
2009
um
the sanctions against russia not bear
his name
but
mr putin is still where he is he still
seems all powerful
how do you feel about the fact that
somehow
nothing seems to be able to shift this
guy
well um
it's very frustrating to watch um putin
carrying on just getting stronger and
stronger
and it's also frustrating that having
passed the magnitsky act
in the uk and actually in 33 other
countries
is not more readily used because
we know that this works and we know it
works because putin got so furious about
it when it first was passed in the
united states and in other countries um
in the united states after it was passed
he banned the adoption of russian
orphans by american families and made it
his single largest foreign policy
priority to repeal the magnitsky act and
he's been following me all around the
world i'm trying to do whatever he can
to stop the magnitsky act from being
passed he sent one of his emissaries to
trump tower shortly before donald trump
was elected trying to get the magnitsky
ad repealed and so we know that this is
something he cares about um everybody
who's involved um in russian opposition
uh in russian politics who aren't there
understand that this is the tool to get
him this is putin's achilles heel and
this is what he really cares about and
so it's really a question of
of using this tool now um instead of
just having it and and if we use it
properly and if we use it against these
oligarchs it will stop him
bill browder thank you very much indeed
for your time
thank you
uh that's it from uh this part of the
show this this morning um i'm still
slightly recovering from tracy brabin's
story about
being in a boot rather than taking
having taking a bus and also the
question of
conservatives defending the rises and
taxes big boarding in a minute i'm going
to hear from sam coats in the take
why
that happens
[Music]